Hey, what's going on?
It's Bill Burr and It's time for the
Monday morning podcasts for Monday,
November 21st, 2060 what's going on? How,
why? Yeah. How's it going? Oh,
I'm doing good man. I hope you guys
are do, Oh, it's a holiday weekend.
Doobie Doobie. Do in school to lead Bop.
You only have to work three days
unless your boss is a fuck and cont
there's always other ones too. Oh,
if you're fucking self employed or if
you're not happy with your home life,
you'll come up with a reason. Right.
To go back into work just
to fucking avoid it. Um,
yeah. You know what, this
year, cause uh, you know,
we've been getting the
fucking kitchen done.
We don't have time to cook and anything.
So we're actually going to a friend's
house for a Thanksgiving, which is,
which is great because they
live in the same city as us,
so we don't have to go to the
fucking airport right now.
All these fucking people
waddling around, you know,
those people just oblivious of other
peanuts. A great fucking human being,
just totally being all about yourself.
Oblivious moment is when fucking people,
you know,
there's a whole herd of people just riding
down an escalator and people like the
second they step off it,
they don't keep walking and get
the fuck out of the way. They just,
they're just all fucking
oblivious. It's like, Ugh,
you would just on the escalator,
this 50 people in front of you,
a hundred people behind
your touchdown. Fuck,
sorry, I got the game
on. What a fucking throw.
What the fuck is going on with
the packers this year, man,
I don't fucking get it. Um, anyway, sorry
about the screaming there. You know,
you've got 50 people in front of, you
got 100 fucking people behind you.
You know,
and people are getting off their kind of
meandering and you're on the escalator
thinking go, go get out of the way before
we all fall down on each other. Right.
For any sort of a thinking human being
going like, oh, assessing the problem.
Well, when in fucking eight
seconds when I become that person,
I'm going to get the fuck out of the way.
So whoever the fuck is 20 people behind
me will not be having this panic moment
because of me going to become
part of part of the solution,
not the fucking problem. Right.
I don't even know what I'm
talking about at this point.
I can't remember the point I
was trying to make, but what,
I know what I'm saying. Yeah.
The kind of fucking people like you know
was that hard? I'm sorry thanksgiving.
That's right. Right. So
we're going to fucking pee.
I have no idea what my point
is. You know what I mean?
I just said a bunch of shit.
I hope it was funny cause God knows there
was no point and I think that actually
is the point of the Monday morning podcast
for all you people out there who you
know who tend to take it
unbelievably seriously.
Those of you out there who think that
I influence the fucking election isn't
that hilarious.
$7 billion was spent to get Trump and all
these fucking people a to get elected.
But you know that all goes
out the window. The second,
some fuckhead who can't
even read out loud,
does a podcast all out the window.
I'll tell you if that's true.
I'm going to start, I'm going to start
charging more for my fucking advertising.
You know what I mean?
Maybe I'll use that as a selling
point in 2017 I evidently I was,
I was the reason Trump got into
fucking office. Oh, Jesus. Hey, hey,
Trump's support. Is he liking
what you're seeing so far? Uh,
you like in these fucking, you know,
you thought Trump was all
looking at fucking people.
He surrounded himself with Jesus Christ.
If they're not an a Nazi fucking movie,
they're like 450 fucking
years old. Rudy Giuliani.
This is like when some old hair metal
band gets back together again thinking
they're going to put out a fucking
relevant album. You're not, it's over.
You had your time. It's fucking
done. You know what I mean?
These guys are going to get the fucking
band back together and start singing it.
What, uh, girls in a
strip club and the devil,
maybe the PMRC or whatever the fuck
people used to sing about back in the day.
I don't pretend enough. Um, you know,
we were fucked either way. All
these fucking people, by the way,
I got to give a shout out to somebody. Um,
what's her name from
Cosmopolitan magazine,
Laura Beck calling out SNL for
the horse. Shit that, that was,
that was that opening completely agreed
when they were saying that the woman who
plays, uh, Clinton,
Hillary Clinton played La Luhya
and it was kinda confusing.
Like is was this a tr a tribute to
fucking, uh, Leonard Cohen Dying?
Or was this a political
fucking statement? And uh,
she kind of called them out going,
didn't you guys have Trump as a fucking
house two while he was running for
president and now all
of a sudden, you know,
you help promote the
Guy Denya I mean, shit,
if I did by trashing both
fucking people, right?
She actually said it was bullshit. It
was fucking hilarious. It's a great read.
I'll give you guys a, uh, a link
to it, but I mean it's a TV show.
That's what they do.
They did that to a buddy mandated
that the fucking Dane Cook,
they had them fucking, uh, host it twice.
He made him a bunch of fucking monies
with high ratings and then all of a sudden
there's a little blip on the
fucking Internet, you know,
tide turns a little bit and then they
use them as a fucking cheap joke when he
wasn't even a, he wasn't even on the
shelf. That's what they do over there.
That's what they do in this business
then at you fucking friends. See,
that's why, you know what you do, you
stay where I stay, right? My little cave.
You do a podcast by yourself and
then no one can hurt you. Um,
anyways, um, so I, uh,
every time I do a stand
up special, you know,
and ends up being a little bit too
long, at least the last couple ones.
So you start thinking, what
if we take this out here when,
if we do a little fucking
thing here and we have to do,
and you end up fucking the whole thing up,
but you really have to do is you just
gotta, you gotta cut off a limb, you know,
you've gotta remove a kidney. Basically.
You just got to take out a chunk.
And I figured out what junk it
was going to be, or I had an,
an idea that that's what I wanted. And
then the director Jay had the same idea.
We took it out and it flows and it
went from a too long of a special.
Now it's like fucking perfect.
And now we're going to, uh, and,
and all I've seen at this point
is just the raw feed of it.
So it's not even like an HD and it looks
way over lit. And am I fucking pasty?
God Damn Whitehead,
I look like an asshole and it
still looks like a good special.
So I'm very excited. I got that
done. F is for family. Second season,
we're starting to fucking, you know,
tighten these things down for
the final fucking edit. And, um,
and then next month
I'm going to start, uh,
the process of which should be a quick
edit is editing the audio from when I did
Madison Square Garden a year ago for
the New York comedy festival, sorry,
hiccups in New York comedy festival.
I didn't almost get emotional there,
New York comedy festival.
Um, and then if once I get,
I get all that shit done right
then I'm just like done, I'm done.
I can just enjoy the rest of the fucking
year. I've got nothing to do really.
Right. And then, uh, then it
starts all over again in January.
You know, it'd be nice if I did cardio
for the rest of the week and just,
you know, then I can fucking throw down.
That's another good thing about going
to somebody's place for the holidays.
They got clean up, you know, you know,
leave with a bunch of fucking food.
It's going to be good. Um,
I'm excited about that and he wants me
to make this fucking stuff and I knew she
wouldn't let me just go
over there. It's like,
why can't I just be the
12 pack guy? You know,
that's the best guy you put on a
sweater, right? You go over there,
you make people fucking laugh to show
up with like a 12 or fucking whatever,
whatever the fuck you want. You know,
I tried this IPA lately and
I'm not really not an IPA guy.
I go in and out of that
shit. I usually drink,
just drink shit that's considered
a white trash beer and I'm,
because I dislike it and fucked up,
you know, I'm not into the taste.
I just won't get fucked up.
Right. And I want you guys to say,
well those IPA A's have a
fucking high alcohol content.
I don't give a shit that. Fuck,
they're heavy. Fucking heavy as hell.
But I tried this one, it was called the
Green Line and I got it. I don't even,
because they only had a
couple beers at this place.
It was this goofy fucking place and
I just wanted a beer and they were,
that's one of the only ones they had.
I actually really liked it. Remind me,
living in Boston,
fucking going out to fucking chestnut
hill and the gray light doe Kenmore
Square. Go to the fucking
socks. Rich gang man, Joe Fisk.
Um, Gary Allen said, oh Jesus,
there's a couple of red sox names
from way back in the day. Anyways, um,
I tried that shit. I actually
really liked it and uh,
I don't even want it you guys.
I'm just fucking talking in
circles cause I haven't been home,
haven't been to my house in like
fucking two months and uh, I've had it,
me and dia had been living on top of
each other and uh, you know, I, uh,
I don't know about her, but I'm,
I'm pretty sick of us being
this close to one another.
So hopefully Tuesday we get back
in the fucking place. Oh, nice.
Fucking throw out,
right Rogers over the top DB complaint
and Sadie fucking pushed off course.
You're going to say that it's what you
say when a guy fucking on a tight end
beach, you that deep as a fucking
corner. How the hell does that happen?
How do you let that
happen? I ask you guys,
he pushed him within five yards.
I think that was all right. Um,
anyways, how about those Bruins? Huh?
Handling Winnipeg? I was all nervous day.
The top two score is in
the league. What did we do?
We put fucking three of them. Three
goals in the second period, right?
Who scored fuck in Mash, Yan fucking
Bergie Belski whatever the fuck his name
is. And then, I don't know fluctuates.
We actually went up for enough of one,
four to one. That's another thing.
When I get back, I got my
Bruins and Celtics package.
I can start watching that shit so I can
really start boring you guys with the
sports talk. You know,
I didn't see the Patriots game today
cause I've been running around.
I haven't been spending time with my
wife, so I took her out someplace today.
She'll come on later, I'll
tell you all about it. And, um,
but all I know is it's the usual shit.
All my fucking friends who
are pats fans like, dude,
why'd we trade Chandler Joe, AJ,
why we get rid of Jamie Collins?
I fucking defense stank
stowed. Um, so I think it was,
you know what, should've been an
easy gay. My kiss evidently wasn't,
but a, I didn't see any of that.
I watched the boxing though.
Who the fuck that Russian guy that ego
Larry or enough was that his fucking
name? Whether it was a real hacky
Russian name was surrogate Culver lev,
which is like every
Russian guy in the NHL Se.
This first name is Sergei
or his last name is cold.
That's really like the John
Smith of Russian names.
So he's fighting this American dude.
So I got to go for the fucking American
and uh, I got to tell you something.
The fucking first, first
fucking round. All right,
Eagle rer off comes out and
he fucking punches Andre Reed.
Is that the guy's name or is
that the guy in the bills?
I can't fucking remember. I'm not a
big box and fan. I love the sport.
I love it, but a, it's been
ruined. It's been ruined.
Cause every three pounds is a new
weight class that as yet another fucking
champion. And then there's like 15
different fucking boxing federations.
It's a shit show. Like there's more
boxing divisions than there are podcasts.
And I'll tell you that's ain't some,
cause there's a lot out there, um,
that, you know what I mean?
When I was a kid, it was like,
it was like fly weight. It was like
flyweight featherweight, middleweight,
welterweight, heavyweight, something
like that. I can't even remember.
I can't remember the fucking divisions
now. Everything's things like,
there's like 15 offshoots of each
one of them. It's, you know what,
it's like those superhero
movies, like back in the day,
like Superman was in a superman
movie. Batman was in a bat.
They didn't fucking know each other.
They weren't all hanging out at the same
place. Maybe on the, the super friends,
they were super friends. They
did at the hall of Justice.
But they only did that. They
did that when they drew it,
but they never had that in
movies. You know what I mean?
Superman was Christopher Reeves.
That was his fucking shit. And a
see Batman, right? Oh they have.
They had Michael Keaton remember that
and he was all sweaty in the locker room
with just a towel around
him wearing the bat mask.
And he got in the face of val Kilmer
and he was like, that's right ice man,
I am dangerous. And then Val said,
clicked his fucking teeth together
and then they all played volleyball,
you know? And then they
were playing volleyball.
Aquaman did come out of the ocean.
Dedi you know what I mean? Look at it.
Batman being like, take
my breath away, dude.
Who Do you know Kelly McGillis gets in
her invisible jet? I can't remember the,
I can't believe the fucking
names I remember for that movie.
I saw that movie a bunch of times.
I was the one that I owned
on VHS when and cut tank.
Tank of buckle [inaudible] right.
I was in high school and everybody
wasn't wanting to get a fucking Ninja
motorcycle and fucking fly f
sixteenths, you know, inverted.
We all thought we were going to do that.
You know this every once in a while
like a movie comes out and you're like,
you know what, I'm going to fucking
do that. Right? And then what happens?
You know what happens?
Geometry, Algebra two and trig.
All of that happens and then you're
like, oh, I'll wait a minute. Wait,
I thought, I think I
was going to fly jets.
Is that what I thought was
going to happen? I'm sorry,
I'm going to be a salesman.
You know I make people laugh. You
know I, you know, I come into a room,
I make people feel good. What you
got a product? I'll do it. Huh?
I you set the cotton potatoes
like this. What if you had that?
I like the guy with the John Riggins
fucking Jersey and the crowd at the
Redskins. Gay Man, 44 was always
a bad ass fucking number of,
there was always a fullback number
when I was growing up. John Riggins,
Robert Newhouse, you know chuck foreman,
he, I think he was a running back.
Was he 44 that was a bad ass
fucking number. Reggie Jackson,
you know, now you, this guy starts,
he's got to live. That's it.
That's a fucking legendary number. I
wouldn't have any fucking hall of famers.
We're 44. I've fucked dead.
How many fucking, just like
skirts were 44. Not a lot.
Everybody ever wore 44 was a
tough mother fucker. Right.
I like to think John
Riggins broke my heart man.
Cause I was a big time cowboys
fan back then. Um, before,
how bout damn cowboys and they kicked
out Tom Landry and Tex Schramm. Uh,
that was just the worst. You know,
I thought Tom Landry was going to be
this forever. You know, I was young.
I didn't know.
I didn't know people get old and their
pastors and by fucked up right. And uh,
I hated the fucking Redskins for beating
the cowboys so much that when they were
in that Superbowl actually rooted for
the dolphins and I hated the fucking
dolphins cause we can
never beat them. And, uh,
when Riggins broke through the line
and whoever the fuck that was on the
dolphins that came by and just grabbed
him by the waist and slid down,
I'm like a greased fucking pole. And
he just kept running that it killed me.
Was it a j Dewey? I don't
fucking remember. Anyways.
Um, how much time have I done here
is a time for the fucking region.
I don't think so. Um, hey, Neha,
you want to come in here and
tell people about your day?
I gotta tell you this shit, right?
So I haven't been, you know,
I've been fucking
busting my ass. You know,
I was getting ready to do this special
and then editing all that bullshit I
talked about earlier. So, you know, if
you don't spend time with your wife,
all of a sudden your wife gets
all upset with you. Like, oh,
you don't spend time with me and
Boohoo who I have fucking needs.
Hey Nia, I'm just, I'm doing a character.
What the fuck did I do with the
market? There's the microphone.
There's the microphone. All right.
Hello. Talk to me. Talk to me goose.
Hello. Um, so anyways, yeah, I
haven't been spending time with you.
So I figured today, you know what,
I gotta go, I gotta do something,
I gotta do something. So I, uh,
took my wife to go see Cassa blanket
today while the Patriots were on.
I got to get credit
for that. Okay. So, um,
I thought it was at this old theater I
was telling you about these guys on, on,
I think Thursday I was telling
them about it. Like there was,
there's all these old theaters out here
that I'm obsessed with where they had
the Oscars throughout the years. Yeah.
I just think of all the great, you know,
Comedians and actors and directors
and everything, they'd been on him.
I love that sense of history.
Right. So you've got the Pantageous,
you've got the fucking who's
mill, what's out in Santa Monica,
the Kodak Theater, all these
fucking places. So, um,
I just remember that one from
the 80s that I always saw,
I guess it was in downtown La. Maybe
that's the one down the other way.
I don't fucking know. But I just looked
him up and I was like, you know what,
I'd love to do maybe a show
there or I might want to do, um,
you know, just go to something. And I,
I looked up that one
downtown and it said a,
there was just a bunch of orchestras
there and then it said it was Casablanca.
I'm like a fucking love Humphrey Bogart.
I'll take, need to go see that shit.
So we go down and of course we show
up in the theater. I want to go into,
there's nobody there.
They're like, oh yeah, yeah,
it's not here. It's at the theater
next door. There's a little old couple.
So you go up and, um, we're walking
around the theater completely
deserted. Amari starting to
curse up a fucking storm. Yeah.
Bill's already getting hot. I'll go
fuck down. I was on the fucking website.
I looked it up. I looked
it up twice. I did,
I looked it up a couple who are
walking with their little bonnets on,
cause it was raining outside.
Yeah. Bill asked like, oh,
is this where they're having the movie?
I was a little more frantic than that.
Yeah, but you got, you
guys come from the movie.
You were old and that was my energy.
It's across the street at the
concert hall and you had your,
one of your classic, you, you,
you made the mistake until you
started having a little meltdown.
I didn't make a mistake because if you
look at the fucking theater up and you
look at calendar, okay, and it says it
was at the Dorothy Chandler pavilion. No,
you click on calendar events and then
it just, it lists and it lists that,
but I think the same person owns the
theater. It's very fucking, you know,
it's like buying a car.
Yeah, we got it this lot.
And all of a sudden you're
down the street. It's like
you're in good fellas now.
A little further down. I don't know
Jimmy. I think I'll pick it up tomorrow.
That's what they did to me. Well, anyway,
it was across the street at the Walt
Disney Concert symphony looking thing that
looks like a fucking exploded
golf ball designed by Frank Gehry.
It's like one of the most like impressive.
It's like the drummer from extreme,
isn't it? No, it's a very
famous architect, like
what you see here? Get the fuck out,
get the fuck out, get the fuck out.
Get the fuck out. What are you singing?
We won't try to, it's one of the
widest. Trying to be funky songs ever.
Get the fun gout. That one.
And then there's the, uh, okay.
Some Big Joan is my name anyway, and
building my game. It's one of the worst.
This building was one of the most like
impressive pieces of architecture in Los
Angeles. It's a beautifully designed
space and bill is just like,
I couldn't help but laugh at you because
you were just muttering and cursing and
stomping around in the
rain and you're like, oh,
I to go into the gray ones too.
I hate that. Super Modern Shit.
I've done shows in those
stupid symphony fucking things.
You feel like you're in front of the,
like the council and one of those
superman movies where you're like down.
They're all fucking up above
you and they're behind you.
I fucking hate those
things. So I was like,
I don't want to fucking go into
this thing. So I end up show,
but it's like I got to take her to
this thing. It's fucking raining out.
So Nice. All like whoa.
Could go to the theater another time
when it's a dance event to like calm you
down because it's now we're going to
another building. No big deal. You know,
we're going to go seek it. And then
what happened? Don't worry, we show up,
we show up and I go, hey, can I get,
and I literally said to you, go,
now we're going to fucking go to this
stupid ass fucking theater, right?
It's probably in some small
room. It's gonna be you,
me and four other old people and the
movies, the movies almost ready to start,
right?
So we fucking show up and I
go up to the booth and I go,
yeah, I need two tickets to
Casablanca. And the person's like, oh,
I don't know if there's any
tickets left. And I'm like,
what are you talking about?
It's raining. It's Sunday.
Football's on his fucking
movies like 80 years old.
And who was going to come
see dad check, right?
And then she finally goes,
well, you can't, I should
be found too. And I'm like,
thank Christ, trying to do
something romantic here.
It's not the right fucking theater. Now
they're going to be sold out. She goes,
you gotta go down to Windows. So I say,
fine. I kept my cool, they're there,
right? The rain and rain enough on my
steaming head that I walked over at,
cools you off a little bit, pulled me
off a little bit and I walk home, I go,
let me get too. And I, they go, okay.
And then they go and the guy goes, okay,
that's going to be $161
right? I go $161 he goes,
each and we both were like,
wait, what are you talking?
So it turned out no way. So this
is what it turns. It turns out,
I think this is way too loud
here. I gotta turn this down here.
It turns out that, um,
what was happening was the La Philharmonic
was going to be playing the film
score while you watch the movie.
It turns out this is a major la cultural
event that basically that was just
going to be a movie for
a few old people in us. It
turns out it's this major event.
Every he's got on like sport coats
and fucking dresses and shit.
I'm sitting there, my wet Hoodie,
Humphrey Bogart in there. What
the fuck's going on? Right?
We're going to view the view the body,
Aaron Eckhart like introduces
the fucking movie. So you know,
you know when you just don't
give a shit, I just said fuck it.
So I light up the card and I go,
let's go in there and then I start
getting this feeling of like,
this might be my, this
might be fucking amazing.
And then there's all these ushers walking
around hitting these things that have
gone boom, boom. Like letting people
know that, you know, that whole,
like you don't want to disturb
rich white people, that,
that things are about ready to start,
whatever that fucking instrument is
called. Um, and they fucking go in there.
Uh, we go in there and, and
like, it's like Holy Shit.
Like we're going to listen to what
the La Philharmonic while we watched
Casablanca and how fucking
great was. It was amazing.
It was such an awesome experience.
So bill kind of fumbled,
fumbled his way into her really
amazing stuff, romantic date.
And I get no credits.
I get no credit because I picked
the wrong fucking theater.
I just totally stumped.
So Kenny and be like, oh,
you see that with the orchestra?
I picked that out on purpose.
I feel like you definitely get points
for you seeing that you saw something
cultural going on and you're, oh, that
sounds cool. Like Nini would like that.
And we went in it, it turned out to be
amazing. So it was, it was great. Yeah.
Aaron, it was bio merit. It wasn't
even a hail Mary, the actor,
the actor came out and
introduced the movie oil man.
Is there another famous Aaron Eckhart?
I don't know. Are you being sarcastic?
I'm being a Dick Right now. Was he in?
No. Was he in? No. No country. All Man.
He was in there. Get out of here
a bitch in the company of men. Uh,
was that him and he was in Salie
Sali. Y'All. You had the mustache?
Yes, he was in that movie.
He was in that movie. Which
woof, that was a movie.
That was a movie they
made up. They made it.
Evidently they made up all of this other
shit. It was just so fucking boring.
Can I just say that? You don't
have to say it. I'll say, come on.
It's Connie's word. It was
Rappaport. Senate. Jerry's in it.
There's a bunch of buttons. Yes. We
have friends that are in that movie,
but that are we a Hollywood
couple of our friends are in it.
That movie was so boring
because you know why?
Because nobody, this is sound
so terrible, but nobody died.
Nobody got no, he nailed heard
like it was just nailed it.
He put it right where he was supposed
to put it. Yeah. There was no hype.
Both my engines went out at 1500 feet.
Should I try to land it in the water or
fly back over the most densely populated
area in the United States. So he put
it in the water. Everyone survived.
The whole thing took in real life, 24
minutes for everyone to get rescued.
It's like, what is the movie about
it? Well, they had to have them have,
you got to have the evil corporate guys
go on. Your couldn't save that jet.
Yeah, but you push some people out on
the way over. It just wasn't exciting.
Tom Hangs is a wonderful actor.
All the acting was great in it.
I want to see what it
was like a serial killer.
I'm so sick of him always being doing
the right thing. That's not his brand.
That's not Tom Hanks, his
brand. He's not a serial killer.
Did he die and saving Private Ryan?
Spoiler alert whenever he was just
sitting there firing at the tank.
You never saw that. Now it's not my,
I'm not into those kind of, I'm not,
it's a warm movies, but son,
a war movie saving private
Ryan is not about a war. No.
10 soldiers that Diana. Well, I
mean, that's literally what is,
but it's more of a metaphor.
It is saving private Ryan
is a medical metaphor.
What is it a metaphor for? Please explain.
You don't even know what
you're talking about.
Do you even know what a metaphor is?
It's an incredible fucking movie.
All right. I believe you. All right. Okay.
We kind of just killed
your credibility to say,
sell these boring and then you're
like, yeah, I'm not into war.
Movies of Saving Private Ryan is almost
unbelievable. Fucker boobs ever saw.
Why does that kill my credibility? Just
because I didn't like sales. I said so.
Oh, I see. That's how it works.
One thing has to do with the other.
I don't know. You've been bugging me
lately. Why? Yeah, I dunno. I just,
I don't want to be a dick, but
you putting on weight. Excuse me.
You're like putting on
weight every fucking month.
You getting bigger and I keep telling
you to fucking do something about it.
I have a condition. You have a condition.
What is a condition bigger and bigger?
Every month I would just have enough
[inaudible].
Okay.
Yeah. The laugh factory
fucking tweeted that out,
so I guess we gotta announce it.
Yeah, I'm going to be a fucking
father. That would kind of be parents.
Everybody though excited for
us. Do you know what it is?
They don't give a shit. I'm actually,
I think people have been people
who have, you know who you are.
We already tweeted day offline, stay
offline. You don't become that person.
I feel like people care. Listen. Why?
Because it's going to bring out all
the people who have nasty things to say
about it. No, because people have lives,
but people have been actually
been very sweet. What? What?
No. You know, you're
watching those fucking,
those ladies screaming at each other
too much and the ones where they sit
around, you know, it was one of the
funny things I saw lately was when you,
you had the fucking Kardashians
on with the sound down. Yeah.
So much of the footage as them just
looking at each other with their fucking
mouth kind of open like slack-jawed
because someone else is talking over the
top. Just going.
I just feel like when Mandy said
to sandy that she, you know,
she couldn't go during the nose job
trip. I felt that she was upset and we,
as the person's talking, they just cut
to their faces. They like doing it.
I can't, it's a visual. They look
like those little pouty cats.
Okay. I mean, okay.
I don't know what that
has to do. I don't know.
I just want you to turn this into a Kelley
rip a moment guys. And this is what,
but where it just makes
me feel like, you know,
I'm starting to understand why
Michael Strahan left that show.
Um, so anyways, yeah, it's official.
It is confirmed. All right. Yeah.
Okay.
No it is. And I'm, and I'm just going,
I'm not going to one of
these fucking assholes.
You're very, you know, you're like,
you're begrudgingly talking about
it and I understand why. I know,
cause I fucking hate parents.
You hate. I hate, I like why
one's on [inaudible] he's just
the hardest fucking job. Yeah.
The most rewarding job, like
blah, blah, blah. And you know,
and then they all say it, they all fuck.
Even like chuck Yeager would
say some shit like that.
It's like really dude flying
a fucking jet up into space.
Like trying to get a kid's
fucking backpack on for
first grade is more difficult
than what the fuck you just went
through up there. You know what I mean?
I think that they play Kate to fucking,
is that the right word to Joe
six pack where they gotta be up?
The real heroes pander, pander. The real
people are the real heroes out there.
The people out there, they're there.
They're there making the
tuna fish sandwiches,
cutting it into four fucking pieces.
You had sex and you didn't use protection.
That's what you did now. All right.
You're not Tom Hanks pretending to land
a fucking plane into the Hudson River.
Okay. You did. It's not exactly
the miracle on the Hudson.
So all Billy Booz bag's going to get a
couple more rights and left in before the
little, the little one comes. And
then I'm going to be, I gotta be,
I gotta be so I got to pick my spots.
That is that is that the idea is that's
what's been happening that you've just
got to go on.
I'd like a little bit of a bender
[inaudible] on a bender the whole fucking
year. And then when the baby comes, you're
going to just like cut yourself off.
Yeah. I mean, what am I doing? Maybe
fucking hung over and we'll be that guy.
No, I hope not. Yeah. No, I'm not
going to do that. No, it's over.
It's done. But then I got, I got all
this great hooch back at the house,
so I gotta kill it. I gotta
kill it before it comes.
You have to like drink all
the alcohol before the baby.
It's not like you're
never going to have a dog.
You gotta make space for like fucking
sippy cups and shit. Don't worry.
Don't worry. Don't worry. It'll
suck in my bottles down there.
Not gonna go on the bar
pretty about making,
you know what? I'll save some of my, uh,
pappy van winkles he had wanted
the most spoiled kid ever.
When the baby's teething, I'll rub
CPAP even when it goes on. It's what?
It's fucking gums. Isn't that what
you're supposed to do? I Dunno. I Dunno.
That's an old school thing, but
I'm already going to do this shit.
Like every time the kid cries, I'm
not fucking going in. I'm going to,
there's this great book that I read
on Norwegian parenting that says that,
you know, when the kid starts crying,
you just, you just kind of, you know,
you creep up to the bed and then
you kind of look and you just go
and then that's it.
You scare the shit out of it and
it understands what's going on.
You're making fun of what I told you
was in the book that I'm reading.
By the way, it's 29, 24 fucking
Washington Green Bay. Just score.
This is a great cam. This reminds me,
one of those old San Diego Charger Games.
Are you watching the football game
while you're doing the pockets? Well,
I don't know. I just thought that
stuff that's not a push in the back.
Get the fuck out of here. Anyways,
what were we talking about? Oh,
you having a kid. Um,
the biggest moment in our relationship
ever. You know nobody. Well,
let's see what happens. Yes.
We've been gone to like fucking
lamaze classes and shit.
Yes and Christ though the classes had
been great. The classes have been great,
but this, this is how far the
fucking progressive left has gone.
There's a fucking line for when
she comes in, it says, mom,
will you sign up at me? I'm thinking
finally name of mother, name of mother.
And then I'm like, yeah.
And then my column,
like I'm finally going to be called a dad
after almost living on this planet for
half a fucking century.
And it just says partner
fucking ridiculous. And what
kills me is everybody in there,
heterosexual, all in a fucking
relationship. Everybody there was was,
there was all straight couples, straight
couples and all the dads were there.
Yeah, yeah, that's true. And let's
just keeps going. Coaches, coaches,
calling them coach. I swear to God, Dude,
I'm going to show up with a
fucking whistle next week.
No fucking Bill Belichick Hoodie and
shit. The fuck are you talking about?
She said, I guess she probably
probably gonna get in trouble.
She said Dad's twice last
class. I didn't hear it. Yeah.
Got Too busy muttering under your breath
about every time she says coaches,
I say fathers, fathers,
I'm not trying to cut out gay people
or people got bagged behind a fucking
Carl's Jr. You know what
I mean? But what about us?
That's just solution. I
thought it's inclusive.
You're supposed to include people.
I'll take second and third billing
behind a alternative people.
What did you think of that? I'm birthing
video that we watched the last one.
Oh, Paulie's. Put a placenta.
You know? That was tremendous.
I don't know. I don't even
know why I'm there in here.
It's all going to go
out the fucking window.
The doctors and nurses are going to tell
you what to do. I'm just there for you.
Fucking yell at me.
It's so fucking stupid.
If I was going through
gallbladder surgery or whatever,
you would not be in there holding
my fucking hand. It's so dumb.
This is just classic you
guys, you know you got,
you got the shit end of the stick on
this thing and somehow you figured out a
way to drag us in there.
I'll tell you right now,
I'm staying north of that fucking sheet.
Yeah. When that guy comes in and goes,
hey, hey, you want to hook up
your own cable? No, I don't.
That's what the fuck I'm paying you
for. I don't want you to be below the,
the blanket below deck.
You don't need to be below the performance
problems for the next three months.
Cause I keep picturing my kid's
head coming out of your Twat. No,
I'm not doing that. I
shouldn't be in there.
My fucking didn't mash that ass, you know?
But you said after you watched the movie,
you leaned over to me and you said,
I understand now why the guy
isn't there. You did. Yeah.
To get yelled at. No,
that's not what it was.
It was to provide comfort. You're
killing my fucking image here. Okay.
So stop showing your image,
dad. Now get over it.
Fuck your image. Um, no. So I'm
going to, I want to be, yeah,
I'm gonna be a sober debt, but on the
road home, I'll tell him rip it enough.
Yeah. Yeah. Oh, just like
every other comic out there.
You're fucking heck.
I told you my last podcast,
I was going for a Boston accent word
and I realized that I was gonna get in
trouble if I said it so that I had
to switch to console. I was like, oh,
I'll talk to you lady.
Oh fuck. Yeah. Cool.
Fucking Ben Bailey looks at me. He's
like, Quan subs like that. It's a new day.
I'm gonna get in trouble if I say to
him and I don't mean anything by it. So,
um, yeah,
anyone's don't end up like Kanye and
never everybody be mad at you. Oh,
he's going to be fine. He
knows what the fuck he's doing.
He was yelling. I mean, to be honest
with you, I don't understand those shows.
Anyways,
there's no band.
Everybody's standing with their cell
phones on and this somebody a rapping and
then they just stick in them. I, it's,
it's, it's for young kids. They love it.
And I'm not going to go there
like, hey, you think this is music?
I'm not going to be that guy.
I, I stay away from them.
I'm going to go see Casablanca in
the rain with a bunch of old people.
By the way, Nia. Yes. Did
you see during the break,
those old people trying to
walk? Holy fucking shit.
I cannot stress stretching and getting a
massage if you can afford to do it once
a month at all. Geez. That was
on a hunched over people. Yeah.
A lot of people roughly my fucking
age to having limps and shit.
Like what the fuck did you
guys do? You know, look,
some of them probably find a
fucking war. Who's kidding who,
but I'm just saying generally
speaking, you know what I mean? I know.
Maybe we should give them a break, dude.
They didn't all fight a fucking war,
you know what I mean? They weren't all
on the front lines is what I'm saying.
A lot of those people peel the potatoes
and they're still fucking limpet.
That makes no sense.
All right, let me, um,
let me read a little bit of
advertising. You know, it's,
it doesn't that feel and
potatoes there. Um, all right.
Blue Apron, everybody, you know, Nia,
I don't know if you realize this,
but not all ingredients are created equal.
Bless Donald Trump's
going to become president.
This is what copy's gonna look like. Now.
Fresh, high quality white ingredients.
Now, does it make a real difference?
So it's important to know where
your food comes. Um, all right.
Affordable for less than
$10 per person per meal.
Blue Apron delivers seasonal recipes
along with proportion ingredients to make
delicious home cooked meals. Uh, choose
from a variety of new recipes each week,
or let blue aprons
culinary team surprise you.
Recipes are not repeated with any
years, so you'll never get bored.
It's flexible.
You can customize your recipes each
week based on your preferences.
Blue Apron has several delivery options,
so you can choose the
one that fits your needs.
And there's no weekly commitment. Ceiling.
You get deliveries when you want them.
Each meal comes with a step-by-step easy
to follow recipe card and proportion of
Greens and can be guaranteed in
40 minutes or less. A blue aprons.
Freshness guarantees,
promises that every ingredient in
your delivery arrives ready to cook,
although make it right.
Check out this week's menu and get your
first three meals for free with free
shipping by going to blue apron.com/burger
you'll love how good it feels and
tastes to create incredible home cooked
meals with blue apron. So don't wait.
That's blue apron.com/burr blue
apron. A better way to cook. Oh,
here we go. Everybody but heal
dope. Dope me undies me on d.
He's no more sweaty nuts. Peduto no
more sweaty berries and switch it up.
Right last started take
to me on these BMDS.
No more sweaty berries, but
[inaudible] fallen off a fucking
fairy. You go into the water,
your balls are still dry. Along comes
the sting ray puts out your rye,
but you could've died
like the crocodile hunter.
I bet he was aware of me undies
when he got stabbed there. Sorry.
Sorry. Australia. Mandy's.
Picture a world where putting on a new
pair of underwear isn't just fresh.
You're stepping into a
better day. Think about it.
Underwear is the first thing you put
on in the last thing you take off.
Unless you're fucking weird, right? No.
You know what? You have a G. I'm
not gonna say that. You know what?
If you really have to just take
a shit and you just fucking like,
you have to shit so bad, you bypass on
doing your belt and undoing your pants.
You just fucking, you know, you give you,
you give yourself the old right there,
Fred Yank and it all down.
You know that's not true.
Most most people when they get
arrested, only thing they have on,
you know that's not true.
You don't have a shirt.
There has been times when you just
have on a tee shirt, isn't it? Anyways,
why would you settle for anything less
than the best feeling underwear on the
planet? Well, because maybe, yeah, you
have different priorities. I don't know.
Please include the following points
during your read. Well, if you write it,
I'm going to fucking read it.
I'm Yonnie's focus is solely on producing
the most comfortable underwear you've
ever experienced.
My friends at me on these sent me a
few pairs a while back and now I can't
imagine wearing anything else. It
really makes each day that much better.
Stop putting words in my fucking
mouth. Yeah, they're comfortable,
but a few of them were way too
fucking a little racy for me.
You know what I mean?
The Greg Louganis cuts there for the
price of two cocktails. Me undies.
We'll deliver your new pair of favorite
underwear right to your right to your
doorstep. Better Day,
guaranteed you try him on if you
then and not the most comfortable,
best failing undies you've ever had and
they'll refund you and let you keep your
first pair for free, including it in the
prices to sweet touch of modal model,
a special fabric made of the best in
class raw materials that are evidentaly
scientifically proven to be
three times softer than cotton.
These Uber Cozy undies are
sold exclusively on the
Mandy's website where you'll
enjoy free shipping in in us and Canada.
Everybody else can go fuck themselves.
And for a limited time, everyone in my
audience gets 20% off their first order.
But you have to go to our special URL URL,
Mandy's dot com slash bar with me
undies. It's a better day, guaranteed.
You have nothing to lose, so
don't wait any law. Go to me
undies.com/bar right now for
20% off your first order.
That's [inaudible] dot com slash bar
all right. How many do we got left?
Uh, all right, we got two quick ones
left. Can you hang in there? All right.
Simply safe, everybody.
Is this a safe place?
You're making this not a safe place?
I'm going to wear a
safety Pitt. Simply safe.
Ever find yourself almost all the
way to work or maybe you're out.
You're out with your family and friends
and you get that nagging failing.
Did I close the window?
Did I lock that door?
Why did I fuck the maid?
Why did I fuck them?
The kids go through look like me. I'm
sorry. It's a Schwartzenegger reference.
You just don't know. It can
drive you nuts there. Well,
you don't have to worry about it when
you simply safe home security. Well,
if you left the fucking window open,
you can set the, well, I get it.
You can't set the alarm. Okay. It's a
nice extra layer of protection to know.
Simply safe is there.
Simply save has an arsenal of sensors
to protect your entire family,
your entire home, and keep
your family safe. Simply safe.
Got Rid of everything that makes most
hosts secure a home security, such a pain.
There's no longterm contracts,
no hidden fees. They won't Gouge.
It's 1499 a month.
That's three times less than what other
companies charge and about $150 less
than I paid for a fucking movie ticket
today. And here's some big news.
Simply safe has just released its brand
new high definition security camera.
This camera is different. You
know what's great about that?
You can actually see the
criminals face, you know,
instead of having an all pixelated
out, you can actually look and be like,
is that my neighbor? [inaudible]
this camera's different.
It connects directly to your security
system and sends your sense to it,
to your smartphone, a
smartphone video this second,
something happens at your home.
What the fuck? That's crazy.
You could see everything that's going
on so you don't have to wonder anymore.
Did that meet your going to be
out at the restaurant, right?
And you just gotta be eating and all of
a sudden some random customs be like,
dude, what the fuck else?
Right. Freaking out.
Instead of just calling the
cops, I don't know what you do.
Checkout simply safe's new camera
today. I'll do that. We'll be sickening.
You know,
you see him grabbing like your favorite
fucking shit out of that house.
Just go to simply safe bird.com right now
that simply saved bird.com simply save
bird.com and filing Nia. Come on in.
MVMT watches pronounced movement was
founded on the belief that style shouldn't
break the bank. Yeah, you should listen
to this. Yeah. What they just said.
This means you spent too much fucking
money. You know exactly what it means.
Don't play dumb with me. What
you call me in here to attack me.
I was like, why? You can
create the advertising thing.
I was going to come back when
you're done. Yeah. And I subtly,
sure I suddenly gave you shit and then
you pulled the emergency breaking down.
Here we are. Okay.
Everybody knows once again,
style shouldn't break the bank.
Um,
the watchmaker's goal is to change the
way consumers think about fashioning by
offering high quality minimalist
products at revolutionary prices.
Nia, I hear you.
With over 500,000 watches
sold to customers on a 160
countries around the world.
Movement watches has just
solidified itself as the
world's fastest growing watch
company. Moving watches start at just $95
at a department store. You're
looking at four to 500 bucks.
Nia movement figured out
by sa. By selling online,
they were able to cut out the
middleman and retail markup,
providing the best possible
price. Classic designs,
quality construction and styled
minimalism. Over 500,000 watches
sold in over 160 countries.
Get 15% off today with free shipping
and free returns by going to movement
watches.com/bird that's
MVMT watches.com/spur.
This watch has a really clean
design. Seriously, okay. Um,
you're going to get a lot of
compliments if you wear this watch.
Now is the time to step
up your game. Go to MVMT,
watches.com/burr join
the movement. All right.
You want to answer a few questions
before we get the fuck Outta here? Sure.
Before we get the fuck at a a,
what's the score to the game yet?
That watch that I have, by the way.
[inaudible] I didn't say you did.
He just taken the bait and Iam just
breaking your fucking ovaries over there.
Um, what does this go to the fucking
game. I'll just show him the highlights.
All right. Hey there. Billy clairvoyant a.
You probably didn't notice this because
I doubt you'll you listen back to your
own podcasts, but there have
been throwback parallels.
I actually listened to my podcast is
I uploaded my just listening to him.
You know, I don't know why I do. He
loves the sound of his own voice.
Um, that's not true.
I've learned to love it.
When you first hear your own
voice, you don't like it.
Now I can't live without it. Um,
I walk around with headphones in my
house just listening to my own podcast.
When Andrew cuts together the clips, he
uses the same date from eight years ago.
Last Thursday was from November 17th,
2008. Oh, he told me he does that.
That's cool. He said in that episode
you made a reference to cash cab,
which was hosting, which was
hosted by your guests this week,
Ben Bailey also a couple of weeks
ago when you first mentioned watching
Westworld,
the throw back clip had you mentioned
the original Westworld once again,
eight years ago to the, to
the day. Yeah, that back then.
That's what I wanted to buy the rights
to it until I realized it was zillions of
dollars and I was like, oh, forget it.
Bye Bye everybody. And Oh, I had it. My
whole representation, all excited. Like,
is he going to do something like
this? We can get a piece of this.
And I was like, oh, that's
too much money. Um, he said,
I'll be on the lookout for more of these
and hopes to exploit your magic. Love.
You Love Nia. Well that's all. Love
you too, boo. That's all due to,
um, what's his face? Uh, Andrew.
Andrew like I think he tries
to find like the parallel,
so that's his homework, not mine.
All right. Thanksgiving recipe a.
They are Billy White meat and I'm
like that Billy White Meat Burger.
The other white meat, the other
white meat. A, the Billy White meat.
Uh,
what are you going to teach us to cook
this year if I don't get another cooking
video? Like the pie crust masterpiece.
I'm boycotting the season.
I'm the single one of my siblings.
And last year I showed up with the pie
and waited till everyone was done to let
them know I made it.
Then I showed them your Wii video and
we had some full fully belly, less full,
I think full belly labs is what you
want to say. Don't let me make a,
don't let me make, let my family down.
Don't let me let my family down
by letting me down. Okay. God,
thanks for all the free labs. I'm
hearing you get through that set.
I know
my eyes are always 10 words ahead
of what I can fucking remember.
I think that's what happens.
So maybe I'm just dumb. Um,
it's going to be sad when a kid's a better
reader than me. Fucking six months in
her baby's going to teach you how to read.
I'm gonna read you a book at my house
whenever I bought read to like my nieces
and nephews,
like there's a point when they stopped
looking at the book and they just turn
around and look at me and then it's like
more pressure on him and I'm literally
reading like the rabbit
goes, hop, hop, hop, hop.
It doesn't go hop it,
it hops. A cow goes moo.
And maybe that helps you out
there. Fucking old and bald. Um,
well I feel like last year
like making a pie crust,
it was like a real fucking
skill that I had. Like,
I dunno what else to show you
guys how to make, um, you know,
if Nia lets me get this fucking
griddle that I want to get, Oh my God,
this is great. Oh my God,
that's fucking griddle.
It's like you love when I Cook, but
you don't want, you don't wanna.
You know what I mean? It's
like you like your freedom,
but you don't want to see how it
happens. You're the same way with food.
You know touchdown fucking
Redskins. God dammit,
because I don't what? What
are you trying to do here?
You're trying to get like every fucking
invention that has to do with cooking or
grilling or smoking or frying. You
want to buy it and it's just like,
where are we gonna put
all this shit? Okay,
let's list all the shit that I've bought.
I'm not saying that you bought it all.
I'm saying that you want to buy it.
Why? I do want to buy it all
and why haven't I bought it all?
Because there's no room for it.
Oh, and who determined that?
I mean, oh, another missed extra point.
Who determined that? Nia. I, you decided
that? I thought it was a mutual. Yep.
It wasn't all right. A buddy of mine
was going to hook me up with this.
Woke up pellet smoker, you said? No.
Well because he tried to act like
he told me it was the size of a,
of a typewriter. Then would be a solid,
and when he actually showed it to me,
he was like, come here, let me show
you. Let me show you what it looks like.
And then I looked at it and I'm
like, and what Universe is this?
The size of a typewriter,
the size of a roof? I said,
it's like a sewing machine.
He goes, oh yeah, yeah.
It's more like a sewing machine. I'm
like, a sewing machine is on a typewriter.
Can I
tell you something there?
That's why guys are great.
That's why I love that dude
forever because you know
we do that for each other.
I don't know if women do. I want to
speak for you guys, but guys do that.
It was a sight. It's the size of a wallet.
You need a kitchen the size of his
kitchen in order to do all the things that
you want to do.
It's a kitchen. It's a portable thing.
It's on fucking wheels. It's in the back,
but we've got like three fucking tables
in the backyard and I can't get rid of
any of those tables for
the fucking potato salad.
You know every piece of furniture I put
in the back yard has a function and we
have used it
in that
function. That doesn't make any
sense. But she doesn't mean no.
You're what you're doing and she,
you've become the dictator or the
fucking backyard. Mm. You're the woman.
I own the backyard. I own the
fucking garage. If we had a basement,
that's my shit. You can have
the rest of the fucking house.
All right, so what are you saying?
I'm saying I'm getting that griddle. Okay.
All right. [inaudible]
oh Jesus Christ. Yeah,
you're going to hear me say that until
I fucking make you a nice fucking steak
and cheese or make some hash browns
or make you a grand slam breakfast.
I've got my fuckings, I've got my fucken.
You've been making all of those things
without the grill cause I may need to
guide. Right. So why exactly.
So what do you need all this other
stuff for if you're so talented?
Because just imagine how good it would
taste if I actually had a fucking
griddle. Even those fucking
stoves that have a griddle,
if the thing sucks because it's
one heat source, so you can't,
you can't have deficiency. Can't move
it around. You can't play with you heat.
It sucks. It's like this
is the temperature. It's
a pain in the fucking ass.
It's one thing if you've got a pot or
a pan, you can take it on the heat.
Take it off. When you're
on your fucking griddle,
you know you want one on one off
and maybe one a little bit on.
Why don't you just get one of those
little electric griddles at the little,
the one my freshman in college. Once
you can put on your counter, well,
when you divorce me. Oh, that's
too sad to say if you ever do that.
Do you ever do that and I'll [inaudible].
It's a grown fucking man to
buy divorcee kitchen products.
Fuck. Are you talking about divorce? Yeah.
I'll go to McDonald's and grab some extra
packets of ketchup for the future when
I need more ketchup. I've done all
that. Nia. I've used shares for tables,
eight pasta all fucking day and
pancakes. I've done all that. Yes,
I'm done this, we know. Yeah. Yeah, you'll
use sick and my self made man, shit,
it annoys you, doesn't it?
I would eat spaghetti with prego and,
and the bread because it will fill
me up and it will last me all nights.
I do all my spots and I would eat pancakes
because it kept me the most full when
I me up like cement.
And you don't want him doing that
for the fucking people out there.
Women included.
Go on and be one to fucking make something
happen and food's a big thing cause
you got to fucking have it every day.
So you gotta have that shit that
fills you up, right? Listen,
don't let this little ray of Sunshine
fucking rain on your parade. Okay,
I'm here for all you guys.
I'm the positive guy. I'm
the motivational speaker.
Hey, speaking of motivational, what the
fuck's going on with the PNID ex guy?
Did he become a Vegan or something? Well
first of all, he's not to P90x anymore.
He's got a different thing late
night. Yeah. Yeah. But now Tony Horny,
he's looking a little like he's
not doing his pull ups anymore.
He's getting older. He's looking like, um,
I dunno. He's looking
all veggie. Hmm. Anyways,
so I don't what I'm
going to make this year.
I told you. Oh, you mean for
the people? For this guy. Yeah.
Yeah. You want me to,
I'm not showing my fam secret family
fucking recipe of the best stuffing you're
ever gonna have. Admit it.
Most people stuffing fucking
sucks stuffing that bill makes.
Oh my God. It's so delicious.
I've never had good stuff.
The only stuffing I've ever
had that even like me too.
I don't ever like stuffing. I don't roast.
It's always wet and it already
has a bad aftertaste. Yeah.
This is nice and crispy and like buttery.
Oh, it's so good. Yeah. When you got,
you got that fucking barbecue the other
night. You didn't like the corn bread.
They put that weird
ingredient in there. Yeah.
Ah, fumble
you so and so. Read
another question. Dammit.
Okay.
When the fuck did I become such a package
fan? This just certain old NFL teams.
I like actually like the giants.
Can you fucking believe that if the
what they did to my patriots twice, um,
one flew over the cuckoo's nest.
Alright. Hey, they're all Billy bibbet.
Um, it's funny who's Bibbet is a character
in one flew over the cuckoo's nest.
Oh Shit.
Okay.
What's his face downstairs here and old
friend of mine has gone so far down the
rabbit hole of conspiracy theories that
he really can't even function in society
anymore. Oh, that's relatable.
Tell him to start telling jokes.
He's,
he is unable to hold a conversation for
two minutes without going off on some
rambling horse shit about
chem trails, Freemasons,
aliens and all of that crap.
Completely oblivious to the fact that
none of us are interested in hearing about
all that nonsense he reads on the
Internet. It used to be funny,
we were driving out west a few years
back and he pointed out at some lights
moving up in the sky and said, those
are the aliens that follow me around.
Oh, this sounds like a
mental issue, dude. I said,
what does that sign on the right set?
He said, airport neck size cause it.
And I said, yeah, those are airplanes
you check. Yes. And he said,
well maybe some of them.
Wow. He goes, okay,
it's been over a decade of that
kind of Shit. And it's gotten way,
way worse because of this obsession
and the resulting paranoia.
He can't even hold down a menial job.
And all of his friends
have abandoned ship.
He has become addicted to painkillers.
I think he already had a mental issue,
man. Yeah, of course.
Has Been in and out of rehab centers
in hospitals because of bizarre health
problems and is now bordering
on full blown schizophrenia.
Well you don't get that from
reading conspiracy theory, sir.
He kinda did a fucking bait
and switch with that question,
that whole thing in the beginning,
which is like a red herring.
It turns out he's got like
serious mental problems.
What's a red herring? It's just,
it's just a distraction. Exactly.
It's something that you think is
the cause of, you know, I'm not gonna
explain it right, cause I'm tired,
but
oh, I got to use that excuse sometimes
when I use an expression that, oh,
where's my
brain? My brain is mush. Oh Christ.
How many points does fucking Aaron
Rogers gotta put up? You know,
it's like Tom Brady, same thing. How
many fucking points did you get a score?
You just gotta you know, defense. Um,
I want to respect his right to
believe what he wants to believe.
But in the end it has only caused him
to lead an increasingly miserable and
lonely life that will end in a tragedy
and a sparsely attended funeral unless
something changes soon.
So how the fuck do you bring someone
back from so far over the edge? Okay,
well he might be exaggerated
a little bit with the,
maybe he's using schizophrenia as
like a fucking filler word there.
Like, you know, this guy isn't
narcissists. This guy's a sociopath.
This sounds like paranoid schizophrenia.
This is exactly, oh, Dr. Hill.
Are you going to diagnose
that on this fucking one?
If she written fucking
email? Unfortunately,
a member of my family who
went through this exact thing.
I do feel that I recognize it a little
bit. Yes. As a matter of fact, I do.
Okay,
but do you feel like that you can make
that diagnosis as someone who is not a
doctor? No, of course not.
A comedian is not even a podcaster that
you can on a podcast done by a comedian
as not a doctor.
Diagnose this person that you've never
met based on this four paragraph email to
come in here. So I'm giving my opinion.
Either you're going to start a song,
you ask me to come here.
Are you annoyed that that lady
singing about all the ingredients,
you get annoyed when black shit goes
fucking mainstream and then white people
ruin it? Well, I got peas,
greens, tomatoes, potatoes.
That she,
yeah, that thing.
I swear to God,
if that's what my nice little week
long run before everyone else.
If that was my, if that's what
my, which was like I would,
I would go every week. If it was
only a half hour long, I still can't.
I just can't get into the fucking,
I like to sing and part of black churches.
But even when the priest,
regardless of race,
when they get up there and they start
saying that this invisible guy gives a
shit about me, that's, I just, I tap
out. I just can't listen to it anyway.
He wants he cheeses tcis bond chair
that that's the second flat screen
downstairs friend needs per fellows
help. You're not going to be able to,
I let Joel State, he's a, he's a very
positive guy. Um, well you know something,
he's been out there long enough that you'd
think if there was a scandal it would
come up by now. Right. Um, this,
your friend needs professional
help. This is beyond your, um,
this is beyond your pay grade.
Jesus don't Shit on the guy.
He might've just been being funny
just because I'm not shitting on him.
I'm saying that you're,
his friend needs help and this is not
anything that he is qualified to do.
So because he's not much nicer way of
saying the same as beyond your pay grade a
buddy you don't, you get, don't pick
up your brome and keep sweeping up.
This is the job of people with lab
coats. Um, hold on a second. But what
does he say?
He said like I respect his right to
believe what he wants to believe,
but in the end that Dah Dah,
Dah, Dah. Yeah, I don't,
I don't even think he necessarily
maybe even believes, believes it.
He's just got, yeah, he's,
yeah, he's become a data paying.
Claire's had been in and out of rehab
centers in hospitals because of bizarre
health problems. Yeah. He is now bordering
on full blown schizophrenia. Yeah.
I think you just got to be there for him,
but maybe just check in on them and
say, Hey, are you taking your meds?
Are you going to see her
doctor? That type of thing. But you're,
I don't think you're going to be able
to like help him with this hail on you.
Is that what I just sounded? Yeah.
You know, it's fucking coolest shit.
The Redskins still have a band and
they actually have a team song.
I think that's fucking cool.
It's a professional level.
For some reason that all went away.
I hope our baby doesn't get your add.
Why it's worked great
for me. Has It? Yeah.
Yeah, it is. Yeah.
I played drums for helicopters.
Still Chokes you and Amos.
Okay.
Add is is a fucking great thing to
have. It sucks with some shit, but it's,
it's, it sucks when you're in school and
you're going to do poorly in school and
everyone's going to say you're fucking
dumb. But when you get out in the world,
man, it's fucking tremendous.
It's tremendous.
I know I run around all
day long, have a various,
so you don't have it like severely
though. You weren't able to just fucking,
you just get, you know, even
get the lab glasses on tonight,
just fucking diagnosed at everything.
How do you know what I have at us?
Remember when we tried to do that ADT
questionnaire and you couldn't even pay
attention long enough
to answer the question.
You have a part of that was
because I was annoyed with it.
You want to revisit that real quick?
No. Do an Oldie but goodie. All right.
Built my kid is 14 years old, 14 years
old, and he wants a drone for Christmas.
The drone market is huge with
kids these days. When I was a kid,
we wanted to fly something
for the sake of flying it.
Now they all have cameras attached to
them and they hover in a real creepy way.
He's not a punk, so he won't
flip out if he doesn't get one.
His friends have them. So it's
not like he'll eat, never use one.
If I did get him one, he's not the type
of kid to fly it up to someone's window.
So that's not the concern.
I'm coming from a place like if I
didn't want him to get an earring,
uh, more of, don't be that
kid. I might be overreacting,
but that's just something. But
there's just something about drones.
What do you think? Uh, congrats
on the condition. Uh, thank you.
Um, I would say, uh, I
agree with you. No drowns,
no drones with the
cameras. That's too much.
Th the Shit I would have fucking done,
I would have the hottest
chicken in the neighborhood.
I would've had it out there
hovering, hovering near a bathroom.
[inaudible]
of course you would. If he's not,
then his friends are going to,
his friends are going to be like, let's
just take it over here and just see,
and this is a thing, you know,
person watching is jerking
off if it immediately crashes.
So,
so kids are really using drones like
they're, are they, is that the hot gift?
This Christmas is a drone
for a teenager. I mean it's,
it's an amazing fucking thing.
It really is. I mean,
I can't imagine like just flying
over a neighborhood to see what your
neighborhood looks like from the air or
your house. All of that would be cool.
But the, the, the possibilities,
the shit that you could do
with those things, uh, in a,
with a juvenile brain, I don't
know. I would be nervous.
One of the best things my parents did
was they never let us play video games.
They never let us play it. They
just, you're not getting that.
It's going to fuck with
your schoolwork. You know,
it was funny as I still
fucked up in school,
but the great thing is is I'm
not a fucking 48 year old gamer.
You know, like I just think
that's, that's really like a,
I, I, you know, I kinda judged
that shit like after a while. Like,
like what are you, what are you
doing? You know what I mean?
What you want to go outside, like
the amount of time that people spent.
You could learn a language, you could
learn how to play an instrument. This,
I'm literally doing
whatever you get delta is.
You could go out and do the
things that I find interesting.
The fuck if you're into video
games, go ahead and play it.
But I'm glad that I didn't cause I wasted
enough time watching fucking sports.
I can't imagine, cause I told you,
I've always said I tapped out
after grand theft auto three.
It literally took over my life.
I'm so sick of this fucking commercial
where they show the Ford F-150 with the
aluminum bed and it has,
it doesn't have any bedliner and they
dropped the fucking toolbox into it and
then they showed the
Chevy with the steel one.
This is such bullshit
advertising. What it's really is,
is I bet the Ford gets better gas mileage
because it has a lighter bed and then
all you do is just put that to the same
rubber guard that comes in all pickup
trucks.
What kind of a fucking asshole buys
a pickup truck and you don't have the
bedliner the fuck outta here. Fuck Chevy.
Even though I like this Silverado.
All right. Thanksgiving debacle.
Old Billy Turkey legs.
Don't get your kid a drone if you don't
want them to have the drone. You're the,
you're the parent. Alright. What's that?
Another add moment that I'd leave it
there. I'm going a little debacle with
lady
about Thanksgiving. I want my
girl to come to my thanksgiving,
but it starts like only
an hour before hers.
Okay.
Right. I'm in a little bit of a
Dabbagh for my lady about Thanksgiving.
I want my girl to come to my thanksgiving,
but it starts only an hour before hers,
but they are in the same time town.
Mind you, mine's at my aunt's
house and hers is at our parents.
Mine starts at 12 hers starts at one
30 I wanted her to come to mind for a
little bit before hers,
but she's not having it because
she's got to help her mom cook. Well,
this is easy,
so you just say you'll be over there and
fucking one 30 and you're just going to
make an appearance,
which you can make it not
see your family on thanksgiving.
He said, on one hand,
I'm super salty and want to be a huge
and want to make a huge deal about this
because I really want her there
and I think she's being selfish,
but on the other hand, I understand
she's got to help her mom cook and stuff.
At least that's her excuse.
I know she loves her family,
but it really pisses me off because
she's never been to my family shit.
But I've got gone. I've
gone to plenty of hers.
Hers offense is that she's never made me
miss any of my family gatherings to go
to hers. But my family is a bunch
of nut jobs and you get the point.
A old Billy burnt Dick. I
could use some words of wisdom.
I'm a huge fan. Thanks. And Go fuck
yourself. Happy holidays. Huge Fan. Well,
I mean this is all your doing
so you can undo all of this.
All right.
Yeah.
You know, you just got to put your foot
down and just say, listen, I respect,
I understand you got to help you
mother cook. But I, you know,
I want to see my aunt, my family on
Thanksgiving. So I will go over there.
I'll be there over the
for an hour. All right.
And then I'll be over here
at one 30 in time to eat.
And if she has a problem with that, um,
just ask her why do you have a problem
with that? This is perfect. I'll, I'll,
you don't have, you don't have to
come, you don't have to come to, to,
uh, my family of nutjobs as you say. And,
uh,
yeah,
she tried to get out of going to your
families is what I'm wondering because
most people, I feel like in the
situation, you just split it up.
So she's got to go help her family cook.
Okay.
You could go over there with
her while they're doing that.
Talk to the dad of the brothers, whatever.
I don't know if they're going to be
cooking or whatever. Spend that time,
have the meal and then the
two of you then go to your,
your family's house for dessert and
like coffee and a movie or game night or
whatever. Yeah.
There's his starts early. It starts at
12 there starts at one 30. So I'm saying,
I just, I tell, listen, you go
over to your mom's house, you cook.
I'm going to all my aunts from 12 to
one I'll be back at one 30 show up like,
and then you show up at like one 40.
You don't even have to spend like
an hour though. That's nothing.
Hm.
He goes, you'd like the food isn't
going on the table right at swell.
Everyone's going to like saunter in
around 1230, 1245 sit down then eat.
I would take, it's going to be there.
This, this is what I would do.
I would say this is the deal.
I'm going in there for an hour, then
I'm gonna go over to one 30, right?
One 30 I'll be at your place, but
next year we're going to my families.
This isn't like,
I'm not going to like never see my
family on Thanksgiving again. Right.
I would never do that to you. I,
you saying I can't see my
family anymore on thanksgiving.
Let's just go, yeah, go to his
family's and just say, Hey,
text me when you guys are about to like
sit down because she's going to cook and
do all this other stuff.
So it was like texting me when
you guys are about to sit down,
I'll let you know where I'm at
with my dinner and then I'll just
come over there and that's,
what do you need to do is say it
totally calmly do not trasher do not,
do not insult. Say anything insulting
about her family. Do not let her, uh,
when and when you stay calm,
if she does that thing where she
then tries to bait you into a fight,
do not take the bait. Just ask
her why she's reacting that way.
Or just just stay calm.
Stay on target star wars. Right. You just,
you just make your points and that's
it. Yeah, that sounds reasonable.
Well there you go. So you like how
great a move you is Casablanca.
And it was really nice. I finally
understood the fucking movie.
I always got confused. I
understood the love story,
but I didn't quite understand, you know,
unoccupied France and the talking
and like Nazi Germany and shit.
It's just like they're taking over
your country and it's just like,
I guess they hadn't, their power hadn't
gotten to that point cause it
was like Italians soldiers there.
There was German soldiers and there was
fucking these, these German Nazi guys.
I don't know.
I'll have to watch it again and maybe
read a little bit of fucking history,
but I actually understood the love
story this time. It was fucking great.
How beautiful was that woman too,
Huh? Yeah, she's beautiful. Yeah,
she was like modern day. Beautiful too.
A lot of them back then or back then.
Beautiful. You know
what I mean? Like, Hey,
what he say they're fucking
Ellis island. She's a classic.
Uh, ah, there she goes. There you go.
Sleeping like a damn dog lately
because of your condition.
Because of my condition.
I think you're being a
jerk about it. Personally.
I think you're being a jerk about it.
I'm not. How, why is my fucking leg hurt?
Oh my God. I'm an analyst.
Those fucking people in the
orchestra pit just will fucking Lisa.
That one guy was like
55 just sitting there.
He looked like he just
fell off a motorcycle.
Um, anyways. Well I'm glad you had a good
time. I hope you enjoy it because uh,
I'm watching all the rest of the football
Sundays from here on out is I empty
the liquor cabinet. So it that our last
Sunday out. Is that what you're saying?
Until now I would like to do
that. I'm going to actually,
and I've been looking up museums and
shit on the download trying to understand
arteries. I never understood it
and I find that I, I like, uh,
uh, I forget what period it is. It's the
van Gogh in the period out to van Gogh.
I liked that shit. That's
cool. I liked that abstract.
I'm starting to understand that.
What? You don't need lines,
you have colors to suggest moods.
It's like, all right, let's get shit.
I know it looks like a five-year-old.
It's always going to look
like a five-year-old.
Didn't see like modern art do you think
or do you like them more old classic
stuff. Uh, like the van Gogh versus
the Jeff Koons. I don't know
who. Jeff criminals. Andy Warhol.
Andy Warhol was the original hipster is
brutally, brutally fucking overrated.
Oh, hot take and was not a nice
person. And what [inaudible]
did you like? Basket? I like
basket. What's that to do?
Looks like saving and
Glover. But he painted
safe young Glover. Wow. Oh my God.
I haven't heard that name
in awhile. Uh, yeah. Seed.
Sorta like the weekend
before he cut his hair,
he was doing like an homage
to basket. Yeah. Yes. That's
John Michelle a basket yet. That's the
most modern person I listened to. Yeah,
to the point I preordered his
next album. I know I love,
I got the first two songs
either I want to hear it. Oh,
you should listen to it
after this. Absolutely.
As I fall asleep because of my condition.
How far are we talking about my
condition? Not that much. Right.
What do you mean? Like we're not going
to get into all like all the specifics.
No, we're not. I'm just something
the sex and all that pictures. No,
none of that shit. It's
just like the kitchen.
You just got to know what got read down.
Just know that I share enough.
There's too many fucking Weirdos
on the fucking Internet. I don't,
I do not understand people that post
pictures of their children, you know,
because you get excited because there's
fucking hallway address right above your
fucking head for the,
for the family photo because they're so
cute and you just want to like show off,
you know.
But I definitely understand
why we will not be doing that.
All right.
This is probably a conversation that
should have happened off of the podcast.
All right. You're fucking cool. And um,
what the fuck did I do to my leg?
I just laid down and I feel
like I hyper extended my knee.
Who is it that comedian?
What's his name? You always
bring him up, Richard.
Can't I know. Uh Oh. Robert
Klein. Robert Gla, Robert Klein.
I can't stop my look.
Very good. Look at you.
[inaudible] saving Glover and you hit me
back. White style little Robert Klein.
All right, that's the podcast for
this week. Go fuck yourselves.
Have a wonderful Thanksgiving and I will
be checking in on you on Thanksgiving.
No, you will not so well.
No, you will not. Listen,
we're going to eat at one 30.
I'm going to do a podcast at 12
at my parents' house. You can't,
you can take things giving
off. People understand. Yeah.
I believe you or people
said money never sleeps
in 24, seven. What are some of
that stupid shit? They sleep.
We grind. Yeah. I'll let dumb shit like,
like Bill Gates isn't doing that. You're
going to do a podcast on Thanksgiving,
what is wrong with you? Or maybe you'll
do it the day before thanksgiving.
That's a big pet peeve of
mine when performers over
talk about how fucking hard
they work, you know, and they take
those pictures of them where they look,
they've got their head down like
they're fucking exhausted, you know,
and then you just, at least to
these fucking and pose compliments,
you know, lot of people would stop.
I feel like I'm just beginning.
But that's essentially what you're doing.
If you're going to be working
on thanksgiving. No, no, no.
That was a really weak way
to try to manipulate it back.
And now I'm going to do it. So if you
just want to have the argument now,
cause I'm going to do it. No, I'm
too tired. Yeah. You go, go to sleep.
Seriously, you're putting on
a lot of weight and Oh my God,
I'm not attracted to you right now.
I just don't understand what it is.
That's not true. Don't say that. Yeah.
He just told me I looked beautiful.
I do look beautiful. You still look great.
You're all fucking baby Mama. Belly.
You're all belly. So
anyways, all right. I'm a,
I don't know.
I'm going to figure out how to make a
fucking pan into a griddle and make myself
something because I'm an adult and
I, I can't fucking have a griddle.
I'm sure you'll figure it out.
No, I'm getting that grill.
I'm getting rid of those
fucking tables out there.
There's too many fucking tables.
What do we have in the last sample?
Is Jesus coming back right in our back
fucking yard? That long winded do.
She's going to sit there
and [inaudible] trashing.
Yes. You trashing Jesus. Easy.
Yeezys county. He goes by.
Yes. Easy. Hey radio. Fuck you.
Um, I want to get, I'm
going to get that big. Oh,
just yelling at a fucking what
do you, what would you call that?
What is radio form of communication. Yeah.
Yell at a form of communication and
that cancel a show at the fucking,
he has to be the Magic Johnson
House. Fuck you a internet,
but you internet can't on a string,
but you ham radio.
We get it. Kevin Hart's funny. But So
San Jose kid I saw and fucking
the new def jam. First of all,
Tony Rock flushing it as a host. Tony
Rock's a fucking star by the way.
I remember years ago when he had a
sketch show, Mexican guy fucking pop.
He pops on TV. Robert, I forget
his last name. You tweet Tony,
not Tony Roberts. Tony
Roberts. I've known no,
the name of the comic that you
liked. He tweeted about him.
His name is Robert something. Oh
yeah, he was fucking hilarious.
Fucking hilarious and didn't give a shit
if the crowd liked him, he had that,
the fucking Luther Vandross joke. Oh
my God. Yeah. I don't want to ruin it,
but yeah, just definitely check that out.
Cause if that's how funny that shows
is, that show is back in a, in a, uh,
a big way. And it was great to see
Tony rocket in that Gig. You know,
definitely deserving ending on
a positive note. That's right.
Go fuck yourselves.
I will talk to you on Thanksgiving and
that stomping you hear in the background.
We'll be near unapproved family.
Supposed to be making stuffing.
All right. Go fuck yourselves. Have a
great week. Great. Short week. Alright,
and off to Wednesday night, the
greatest fucking night ever.
If you're a young man, right?
You go back to your hometown.
What's his face to thrill ride the throw
ride did a great rant on that. Who?
The thrill ride? The one. The one man
fucking, Oh yeah, that guy weed. That guy.
That guy should be in the WWE. He's one
of the best people on the fucking mic.
I forgot about him. Yeah,
he fucking said that.
That's the night you go
back and all the women,
you know you went to high school
with that you were afraid to talk to.
Now you come back, you got
your little man mustache.
You make something happen the night
before Thanksgiving can happen.
That's right. Okay.
I love Thanksgiving. You I
love, but Thanksgiving is,
if we just rub it in the fucking
English England's face, you know,
take debt. Right. But no,
there's a lot of people in this country
that think it has to do something with
our independence with England. Yeah.
What am I, nothing to do with that. Well,
that's one of my favorite things to do
is I say that to fucking a London ears
and shit. Oh, fucking one. I
forgot to bring up. There's a,
I got to do another benefit.
Uh, speaking of that, um,
a buddy of mine who did stand up when I
started out and then moved on to writing
, uh, Pete come and, uh, such
a great guy unfortunately, uh,
passed away a Oh God,
a couple of weeks ago.
It was an absolute shock.
He's like a fucking year older than me
was in great health and just a had a
heart attack unfortunately.
So we're going to be doing a benefit at
the laugh factory on December 6th. Um,
tickets will be going on sales soon. I
should probably know by a thanksgiving.
But um, he's got two beautiful
twin boys to only 10 years old.
And um, the great things
going to be honest, so great.
Was Jamie Masada put his name
up on the, uh, the marquee.
I'll never forget that he did that.
That was such a great thing that he did
that cause Pete hasn't done stand up in
a number of years. It was great that
Jamie remembered him. He's a great guy.
Jamie Masada. He remembered him.
He put his name up there. And uh,
so there's a bunch of
Boston guys I haven't seen.
We're all going to be on
the same fucking show. Um,
and I'm trying to think like the last
time we all worked together like that,
it was probably the fucking
cow loon about 20 years ago.
So it's going to be a good reunion.
We're on, we telling great stories about,
uh, p coming. So, um, yeah,
it's going to be December six,
and I'll get you guys that link as
soon as I get it. If you're in town,
you'd like to have a laugh, a to
great cause. All right. That's it.
They Fuckos have a nice thanksgiving.